FOR THE AIR FORCE.
THAT EQUALS THE TOTAL FOR
ALL OF LAST YEAR.
TONIGHT WE CONTINUE OUR
SERIES LOOKING AT THE
CHALLENGES AND OPPORTUNITIES
FOR AMERICA'S
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THIS EVENING CORRESPONDENT
DOUGLAS KENNEDY REPORTS ON A
NEW WAY OF GOING A LONG WAY
IN A SHORT TIME.
>> THE VERY SIMILAR TO FACE
TRAVEL.
>> AS THE LEAD SYSTEM
ENGINEER AT NASA ANITA SAN
GUPTA NASA GOING SOMEWHERE
WE HAVEN'T GONE BEFORE SHE
IS TRYING TO GET US THERE
FASTER.
>> TECHNOLOGY REALLY OUT OF
SCIENCE FICTION.
>> TECHNOLOGY INSPIRED BY
SCIENCE FICTION ACTUALLY A
SCIENCE FACT.
>> CALLED HYPERLOOP OR TUBE
TRAVEL AND ALLOW HUMANS TO
GO FASTER THAN THE FASTEST
HIGH SPEED TRAIN EVEN FASTER
THAN SOME OF THE FASTEST
PLANES IN THE SKY.
YOU WILL BE ABLE TO GET TO
KANSAS CITY TO ST. LOUIS OR
NEW YORK TO WASHINGTON IN 30
MINUTES OR LESS.
>> WE ARE TARGETING A SPEAK
SPEED SPEED OF 1,000 ROUGHLY
700 MILES PER HOUR.
>> TUBES CREATE A LOW
PRESSURE ENVIRONMENT ALMOST
COMPLETELY CUTTING OUT DRAG.
BUT IT'S THE MOTOR THAT'S
GOING TO ALLOW HYPER LOOP TO
COMPLETELY CHANGE THE WAY WE
TRAVEL.
SO YOU ARE BASICALLY
DESIGNING A STRAIGHT AND OUT
VERSION OF A CONVENTIONAL
REPORTER MOTOR.
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
IT'S CALLED LINEAR ELECTRIC
MOTOR.
WHAT THAT MEANS IS YOU HAVE
A REPORTER BUT THEY ARE
ACTUALLY STRETCHED OUT.
ONE PORTION ON THE UNDERSIDE
OF THE VEHICLE WE CALL THE
POD AND THE OTHER SIDE ON
THE BOTTOM OF THE TRACK.
>> START UP COST WILL BE IN
THE BILLIONS.
NONETHELESS, MISSOURI AND
COLORADO BOTH WANT TO BE
TEST SITES CAN DATZ IS HYPER
LOOP LAY LIAISON ONE OF THE
OBSTACLES IS WRITING
REGULATIONS FOR BRAND NEW
TECHNOLOGY.
>> PRESSURE SYSTEMS LIKE
PLANES AND LAND SYSTEMS THAT
ARE LIKE TRAINS.
WHO IS GOING TO REGULATE ALL
OF.
THIS THE GOVERNMENT THINKS
WE ARE A RAILROAD BUT IN
REALITY WE ARE A LOT MORE
LIKE AIRPLANES.
>> NO MATTER WHAT SAN GUPTA
SAYS HYPER LOOP IS THE
FUTURE OF ALMOST
INSTANTANEOUS TRAVEL.
>> WE HAVE NOT HAD A NEW
MODE OF TRANSPORTATION OVER
100 YEARS.
SO THIS IS A WAY THAT YOU
CAN GET FROM POINT TO POINT
ACROSS LAND MASSES.
>> ACROSS LAND MASSES BUT
LOCATED WITHIN CITY CENTERS.
SO YOU WILL BE ABLE TO SKIP
THAT LONG DRIVE TO THE
AIRPORT OR TRAIN STATION.